hello i'm matthew hassell and i'll be
teaching the reinforcement learning
module together with hado and diana and
today i'll be talking about models and
planning
in the past few lectures we already
covered quite a bit of material so we
started with the bandits this minimal
instantiation of the rl problem where we
are allowed to disregard the sequential
nature of decision making and focus
exclusively on trading off exploiting
existing knowledge
versus
exploring alternative courses of actions
that might seem so optimal now but that
might turn out to be even better as we
gain experience in the environment and
the world around us
we then discuss dynamic programming and
model-free algorithms as to families of
ideas and approaches that allow us to
solve both prediction and control
problems with and without access to a
complete specification of the
environment
finally we introduce function
approximation as the leading approach to
scaling up these families of ideas to
settings where we might have very large
state spaces or even continuous state
spaces
if we look back at dynamic programming
and model 3 algorithms we can roughly
sketch the underlying principles and
differences between the two in the
following way so in dynamic programming
we assume we're given access a
privileged access to a complete exact
specification of the environment
dynamics that includes both the state
transition and the reward dynamics
we then just need to solve for this
perfect model and we don't need to
interact with the real environment at
all
in model 3 algorithms instead we do not
rely on any given form of model instead
we learn values and policies directly
from interaction with the environment
in between these two extremes there is a
third the prototypical family of
algorithms which is typically referred
to as model-based reinforcement learning
here we are not given a perfect model
but we do attempt to learn at least an
approximate model but while interacting
with the environment
and then we use this learned model to
derive values and policies
a visual depiction of the model-free
algorithm would be seen as implementing
this loop where we act according to our
current value estimates and our policies
to generate experience but then we use
this experience to directly update our
values and our policies and instead the
model based algorithm would add a step
of indirection in this loop whereby we
act according to our current value
estimates and policies just like in
model 3rl but we use the resulting
experience to learn a model of the state
transition and the reward dynamics
then we can use the learn model instead
of the experience directly to update the
values and policies
thereby closing still the loop
and of course boundaries between these
two families of algorithms don't need to
be extremely rigid and we can perfectly
imagine to combine the two ideas we use
experience to both update values and to
learn the model we can still then use
the model to perform additional updates
and to
refine our value estimates and today we
will actually discuss the popular
instantiation of this idea which is the
dyna algorithm
but whenever we delve into a new topic i
think it's always good to stop a second
and reflect on the motivations that
underlie a family of ideas
for instance there is obvious
disadvantages to this line of attack
if we first learn a model then we use
the model to plan a value function there
are two sources of errors because
whatever model we learn from data is
likely not to be perfect it will
incorporate certain approximations or
certain errors and these will compound
with additional errors that arise when
planning with the model to estimate
values
in contrast if you consider model 3
algorithms they use real data that is
always correct to update the values and
therefore there is only one source of
approximation which is the value
estimation process itself
despite this though there are reasons to
believe that model-based reinforcement
learning could could be quite effective
the first of these reasons is that
models can be learned with supervised
learning methods which are very well
understood and very powerful and
effective
additionally explicitly representing
models can give us access to additional
capabilities we could use them to
represent uncertainty or to drive
exploration
and finally but not less importantly in
many real world settings generating data
by interacting with the environment is
either expensive or slow or both of
these
and instead computation is getting
cheaper and cheaper by the year
therefore using a model to perform
additional updates could allow us to
trade off compute for a reduction in the
number of interactions that we need with
the environment and this will make our
algorithms more data efficient and
therefore extend the range of problems
we cannot successfully apply them to
we will start now with a bit of due
diligence in a sense so we'll start by
discussing different types of learned
models and how to train them and only
then we will delve into concrete
algorithms for planning
but before we go there if you need a
moment before jumping in this is a good
spot for a break
if we're going to learn a model and use
user model for planning
the first thing to discuss is what
constitutes a model in the first place
and in this course a model will be an
approximate representation of an mdp
and for now we will assume that
the dynamics of the environment of this
mdp will be approximated by a parametric
function with some parameters data
and that states and actions in the model
are the same as in the real mdp
and also we will assume that given
states and actions sampling from the
model will estimate the immediate
successor states and the immediate
rewards that we would get by executing
those same actions in those same states
in the real environment
and it's good to realize that this is
not the most general characterization of
a model there are other types of models
we could consider they are quite related
to this but different and we will
actually discuss a few of these in the
in following lectures so for instance we
will consider and discuss non-parametric
models where we use the data directly to
sample transitions in the environment
and also backward models that models for
instance the dynamics of an inverse mdb
rather than the mdp you are directly
interested in
and also jumping models where the
actions do not directly map on the set
of primitive actions in mdb
we will discuss some of these later but
for now let's focus on the simplest kind
of model because this is already
sufficient to discuss quite a big range
of ideas and the support of a good range
of planning algorithms
so with this premises the problem of
learning model
from experience basically
can be formulated as a supervised
learning problem where our data set
contains a set of state action spheres
and the labels of these are the true
states that we add up the rewards that
we will observe when executing those
actions in those states
and the parameters of the model will
then have to be chosen as in
standard supervised learning so as to
minimize some prediction error on this
data
defining a procedure for learning a
model will then amount
to picking a suitable parametric
function for the transition and rewards
functions
picking a suitable loss to minimize
and choosing a procedure for optimizing
the parameters it does so as to minimize
this loss
so for instance we could choose to
parametrize transitions and rewards
using some linear mapping from a
suitable encoding of states and actions
onto for instance the rewards and the
some encoding of the successor state
and then minimizing the parameters could
be achieved by using least squared this
would give us an expectation model for
instance
and specifically will give us a linear
expectation model
note that this is not the only kind of
expectation all we could consider so for
instance using the same kind of loss
this same mean squared error we could
for instance parameterize the model
itself both the reward and transitions
using a deep neural network and maybe
use gradient descent instead of least
squares to optimize the parameters
regardless of the specific choice of the
parametrization though it's good to
understand what are the pros of cons of
expectation models in general so some
disadvantages for instance are quite
obvious
suppose you have some macro action that
randomly puts you either to the left or
to the right of some wall
well an expectation model will would for
instance put you inside of the wall
which might not be a physically
meaningful thing to predict in the first
place
interestingly though the values
could still be correct so if the values
specifically are a linear function of
the state or absorb the encoding of the
state then actually
the linear transformation will commute
with expectation and therefore the value
of the expected value of the next state
will actually be the same as the value
of the expected next state even though
the expectedness state might have some
[Music]
peculiar features like placing you in
the middle of the wall
and
this actually applies regardless as to
the parametrization of the model itself
so it only requires the values to be a
function a linear function of their
state
representation but additionally if both
the value and the model are leaner then
this even applies to enrolling the model
multiple steps into the future
which is quite powerful and interesting
property
it might still be that we're not willing
to accept this trade-off so we might
not be
it might not be possible to make either
the value or the model linear
and in this case maybe expected state
might not be the right choice because
the values that we can expect from
expected states might not have the right
semantics we might not be able to derive
expected values from expected states
and in this case we could consider a
different type of model so we could
consider what's called a stochastic or
generative model so generative model
generates not expectations like an
expectation model but samples
so it takes as input a state an action
and a noise variable and it
it will return you a sample of a
possible next state and a possible
reward
and if we can effectively train a
generative model then we can plan in our
imagination so we could for instance
generate long sequences of hypothetical
transitions in the environment and
compare them to choose how to best
proceed
and this could be done even if the both
the model and the values are not linear
the flip side of course is that
generative models add noise via the
sampling process
there's also a third option which is to
actually attempt to model the complete
transition dynamics so model the full
transition distribution and full reward
distribution
and if we could do so actually both
expectation and generative models and
even values themselves could be all
derived as a sub-product of our model of
our full transition and reward model
the problem is that it might be hard to
model the complete distribution
and or it might be computationally
intractable to actually apply it in
practice due to the ranching factor
so for instance if we were to try to
estimate the value of the next state
with a one step look ahead
this would still require two sum overall
actions and for each action sum over all
possible successor states and things get
exponentially worse if we even want to
look multiple steps ahead
and as a result even if we had this full
distribution model some form of sampling
would probably be needed for most
problem of interest and in that case the
advantage of the complete distributions
compared to for instance just a
generative model might
might be smaller
in the in addition to the type of model
we might want to train there is
the second additional important
dimension which is how we parametrize
the model itself
so a very common choice is to first of
all decompose the dynamics of the
rewards and the transitions into two
separate parametric functions
and then for each of these we can choose
among many different parameter
parameterizations
in this course for instance we'll
consider table lookup models or linear
expectation models and finally also deep
neural network models
in the table lookup case the model is an
explicit representation of ndp where for
instance we may estimate the probability
of observing a given successor state for
a given state action pair as the
empirical probability based on past
experience
and similarly we could parametrize the
reward function as the empirical mean of
the rewards that we did actually observe
in practice when executing a given
action in a given state
in this case we would actually get
a mixed model
because our our table account model
would use a full distribution for the
transition dynamics and an expectation
model for the rewards
it is of course possible also to model
the complete distributions for the
rewards themselves
so let's consider for instance our
minimal reinforcement learning example
where we have the usual two-state mdp
with no discounting and we observe eight
episodes of experience
so once in one in one of the episodes we
start in a we transition to b and we
observe no reward
in all the other episodes we start in b
and we terminate immediately
and in all but one we observe a reward
battle of one
and in one of them we observe a reward
of zero
a table lookup model
would model the complete distribution of
the environment dynamics as in the
picture on the slide so in state a with
probability one we transition to b and
we absorb the reward of zero and in
state b with probability one we
terminated but with probability 0.75 we
observe the reward of one while with
probability 0.25 we absorb no reward at
all
if instead we consider a linear
expectation model
it's good to remember that first of all
we need some feature representation to
be given to us because the linear model
doesn't have the capability to build and
its own state representation
but given this some feature
representation we could encode any state
s as some
feature set for instance a vector and
then parameterize separately reward and
transitions as two linear functions of
the features of the state
so for instance
expected next state could be
parametrized by a square matrix ta one
for each action a
in such a way that the matrix times the
features of the current state
give us the expected next state and
similarly rewards could be parameterized
by a vector wa for each action a so that
the dot product between the vector and
the current state representation gives
us again the expected reward
if we do so then on each transition on
each transition where we execute some
action a some state s then observe some
reward r and next state as prime
there we can apply a gradient step for
instance to update both
wa and ta so as to minimize the mean
squared error on both the reward and the
expected state
we are now ready to delve into the true
heart of this topic which is how to
actually use models to plan and
specifically in this section is how to
do so for the purpose of improving our
value function estimates and our
policies
so
[Music]
the core let's say value proposition of
planning in general of model-based rl is
the capability of improving such value
estimates and these policies by
absorbing compute but without requiring
actual interactions with the environment
as you might remember dynamic
programming is actually
a good example that we have already seen
of a process that allows us to do just
this
the problem is of course that in dynamic
programming we're given a privileged
access to a perfect specification of the
environment but in reinforcement
learning in general we are actually
interested in planning algorithms that
do not make this assumption and instead
perform planning for instance with alert
models such as any any of the ones that
we discussed in the previous section
in this case the simplest approach to
get around this limitation of dynamic
programming is maybe to just directly
mirror dynamic programming algorithms
but plugging in a learn model in place
of the privileged specification of the
environment
if we do so then we can just solve for
the approximate mdp
with what whatever dynamic programming
algorithm you like so you could use
value iteration or policy iteration
and by doing so we we still require some
interactions with the environment
because we will still need to learn the
model
but at least hopefully we can reduce
quite a bit of reliance on on the unreal
interactions and and therefore be more
data efficient
so this approach actually um can work
and it's it's a reasonable things to
consider
but it's also not not the only option so
for instance there's another route we
could take so we could combine learn
models not with dynamic programming but
instead with the ideas and algorithms
that we discussed in the context of
model free agents so this is also
referred to as sample-based planning
and very simply it works by using the
learn model to sample imagine
transitions imagine trajectories and
then applying your favorite model three
algorithms to the imagined data just as
if it was real datas
so for instance you could apply monte
carlo control sarsa or q learning and
just apply the same updates on the
imagine data as sampled from the
approximate ndp that you have learned as
if it was real data sampled from the
environment
and let's consider a concrete example to
make this clear
so this is the same example that we
discussed in the previous section so on
the left we have
the real experience we have access to so
eight episodes
um most of them starting in uh in a
state b and then observing either a zero
or one reward and one actually starting
in state a and the first transition into
b
and in the middle is actually the learn
table lookup model that we had learned
from such data this gives us a hundred
percent likelihood of transitioning from
a to b and a hundred percent likelihood
of terminating it b but with a 75
probability of getting a reward of one
and 25 percent of getting a
reward of zero
the idea of sample-based planning would
be take this model and then sample
trajectories episodes from this model
and this could be for instance the data
that we report on the right so all of
this data is
sampled from the from the model that we
have learned and first we have now two
episodes the sardine both which
transition to b because this is forced
by the model and then in this case both
episodes were sampled the reward of one
when they were in b plus the number of
episodes starting in b and terminating
immediately again consistently with the
model
so what happens if we apply monte carlo
learning to this data well we will get
for instance that the value of a is one
because in both episodes we when we
start in a we collected a reward of one
at the end and the value of b that is
equal to 0.75 because in the
sample episodes
that we that we got from our model
three three-quarters of the time would
serve the reward of one and b so in this
case it's perfectly
in
in line with the troop with the learned
probabilities from the model
so
this is a cool idea and and also using
dynamic programming directly with the
lower model could be a very interesting
approach but but what are the potential
limitations with both of these ideas
as always the the greatest concern is
that the learning model might not be
perfect actually in general we know it
will incorporate some errors and some
approximations and in this case the
planning process may compute a policy
that is optimal for the approximate mdb
but that is sub-optimal
with respect to the real environment
and so
our presentation couldn't be complete if
we didn't discuss how to deal with these
limitations and and there are many ways
we could go for this so one approach
would be very very simply whenever the
model is not good enough it's not
reliable enough just use model 3
algorithms
another idea would be let's try to
reason explicitly about our uncertainty
over our estimates of the model
so for instance this would lead us more
towards the bayesian approach
and finally the third approach which is
what we will delve more in today is
actually to combine model-free and
model-based methods
integrating learning and planning in a
single algorithm
how can we do this well
in the previous discussions somewhat
implicitly we already discussed that
there are two potential sources of data
to potential sources of experience so
one is real experience this is data
transitions trajectories that you
generate by actually interacting with
the environment
and another source is simulated
experience where the data is sampled
from a model for instance a learn model
and therefore is sampled from some
approximate mdp
well the core idea
behind dyna which is a powerful approach
to integrate learning and planning
is let's just treat the two sources of
experience as if they were the same
thing
so
while in model 3 we learn values from
real experience and in sample based
planning we plan values from simulated
experience well in dyna let's do both so
let's apply the same updates to values
and policy regardless of whether data
comes from real or simulated experience
this
very directly implements the picture i
had also shown at the very beginning of
the chapter so where we where i
suggested we could maybe act according
to our value estimator policies to
generate experience and then this
experience could be used both to update
the values and policies directly
but also used to learn a model that
could then generate an additional
simulated update simulated experience
so
let's now discuss concrete instantiation
of dyna because this this idea is very
general but of course we could plug many
different
algorithms to this
and apply very different updates to both
the simulated and real experience
so what does this actually mean in
practice
well a popular version of this idea is
what is typically be referred to as dyna
queue where we use q-learning on both
the real and simulated experience and
this is what it looks like
first we of course need to initialize
now both value function like in q
learning but also a model because we'll
be training it alongside
and then on on each step we can select
actions using an absolute greedy policy
for instance like in standard q learning
and after executing this action we of
course get from the environment
successor state and a reward
with this real transition we can
directly apply q learning for instance
by updating the current q values towards
the usual target constructed by summing
the reward and the discounted max q
value in the next step but we can also
update now the model in a supervised
fashion for instance in a tabular
deterministic environment this would
just amount to storing the next state
and the reward
the next point is where the secret sauce
in some sense of dyna comes in so
basically for each real step in the
environment we now perform n planning
updates where we take some past the
state action pair that we have
encountered during training and we use
the current model to sample a possible
next state and a possible subsequent
reward
and we use this imagine transition to
perform an additional q-learning update
and of course
if as we increase the number of imagine
steps that we do we can basically reduce
our reliance on on the real transitions
and become more data efficient as we
were hoping
interestingly of course there are
many different ways of extending or
implementing this idea so for instance
we could use a different model algorithm
instead of q-learning
also the algorithm writes in the slide
is written for the tabular setting but
of course we could use linear functions
or deep neural networks to represent
both the values or the models
and alternatively we could also vary the
amount of planning that we do over time
so
very intuitively the model typically is
improved and updated along the way so
it's hopefully getting better over time
so maybe we could imagine to perform
more planning updates as training
progresses and we
become more confident in our model
ideally we would actually even have some
form of uncertainty estimates that we
can use to choose how much planning to
perform how much to trust our planning
updates depending on the accuracy of our
learned models
but
regardless of the of the details and
potential enhancement
the important thing is that
even this basic algorithm already
instantiates the most fundamental
properties that we were looking for so
we we can sync in more compute
to learn more efficiently
which i just want to recall again it's
it's really critical if the data is slow
or expensive or unsafe to collect and
and this i can say this uh enough it's
really often the case in many real world
applications
so
let's take a look at what
what happens when we actually run these
algorithms on not a simple problem just
to gain more understanding and intuition
about planning for credit assignment
to do so we will consider a simple maze
which is drawn on this slide at the top
right where on each episode we use the
agent starts on the cell marked with an
s
and from any cell the agent can take one
of four actions which correspond to
moving up down left and right
respectively
the dark cells instead are walls meaning
that if we try to move into one of these
darker cells the action will have no
effect to just bang on the wall and and
stay where we are
the reward is zero everywhere except for
a single positive reward that you
collect when you reach the goal cell
which is the one marked with a g in the
top right corner
under this setting the it's it's fairly
obvious that the optimal policy for any
discount smaller than one is going to be
a policy that leads you from s to g
following the shortest path because any
any any choice of actions that will take
you along the longer path will basically
result in the final reward reward be
discounted more strongly
and this means that we can evaluate the
quality of the policy learned by an
agent for instance by plotting the
number of steps that the agent takes in
order to reach the goal
as a function for instance of the number
of episodes that it has experienced
and this is what is shown in this plot
on this slide this plot is taken from
the saturn embargo book so you can also
read there about more details about how
exactly this was instantiated and run
but at the fundamentally this plot just
shows three instantiations of the
algorithm that i showed in the previous
slide that were ran with different
amounts of planning
specifically it was ran with zero steps
of planning meaning that the algorithms
just revert to vanilla learning or with
five steps of planning or with 50 steps
of planning
and what is really apparent already from
this plot is that vanilla q learning
takes many tens of episodes to actually
converge to the optimal solution
and instead by just adding a tiny bit of
planning so just doing five additional
updates on for every real update the
agent manages to converge to the optimum
much quicker in less than 10 episodes
and as we increase for instance to 50
planning steps the the agent actually
converges in just a couple of episodes
to the optimal policy which is which is
really impressive
might be it might even seem
too good to be true in a sense like what
is actually happening behind the scenes
and
in this slide i'm trying to give you
basically an opportunity to peek behind
the scenes and see what happens to the q
values estimate as we run this algorithm
and specifically let's consider what
happens on the very last step of the
first episode so this is when the is
basically the first time the agent
observes the rewards
so for simplicity we will also assume
that q values were initialized as zero
everywhere
under this assumption without planning
the the first episode is actually fairly
boring so on all intermediate steps the
values where zero when the agent enters
the cell and actually stays zero because
the td error is always zero
our estimates are zero their awards are
zero the value max q value we bootstrap
on is also zero so no update is done
throughout all the first episodes
only a single q value is updated right
on the last transition
and this is the q values corresponding
to moving upwards from the cell
immediately below the goal immediately
below that top right corner so
and when when the agent is doing this
final transition of the first episode
that q value is correctly updated
towards the goal reward
and this immediately makes a greedy
policy optimal in that one cell because
all the other action values stay at zero
but this section value of moving up from
the state just below the goal
becomes actually has a non-zero value
so
all other states that we have seen
throughout the first episode have not
been updated q values stay all at zero
and for the behavior stay random
assuming assuming we are breaking ties
at random but this very last state
is shown in the bottom left
of the
in the maze shown on the bottom left
well that one gets updated to the
correct
to the correct policy
on the main stream on the bottom right
we show instead
the
state
of our estimates of the q values
when we run the same algorithm with 50
steps of planning
and again we freeze the algorithm at the
immediately after we have done run it
for just one episode
but suddenly you can see that the q
values
are now have been updated throughout the
maze so it's not just the final
the final state that has uh realized
what the optimal action is but actually
the the model the estimate of the q
values that the agent has updated
throughout this first episode show a
meaningful direction for many many
different other states and basically the
information of how to move from the
state to goal has propagated almost all
the way to the start
which is quite impressive and the reason
is that when you do update that first
that last cell in the in the in the
episode you then start sampling 50 more
updates on imagine transitions from the
model which means that on each of these
other 50 planning updates we will we
will be able to propagate information
from the new updated q values backwards
in state space
and this means that well in this case it
doesn't quite solve the problem in a
single episode but it will just take
just a couple more episodes to correctly
propagate all information for the state
space and figure out what the optimal
policy is
of course this is
this is not all roses right then
there are always certain critical issues
with model based rl including the fact
that in some cases our model will be
wrong
and in in this experiment i'm trying to
give you some intuition of how
wrong models can affect learning in a
model-based rl system
so to to
gain some intuition of this let's use
again the same algorithm to investigate
how an incorrect model may affect
training and we will do so by simulating
the this this model being wrong by
having a sudden change in the dynamics
of the problem
this means that the model learned from
the agent in the first half of training
will suddenly be wrong because this the
world itself has changed
but the effect of this on learning will
be quite different depending on the type
of error
let's see what i mean by this well
in the first setting we assume that at
the beginning of training the
environment looks like on the grid on
the left where there is a short path
between the state marked as with s as
usual and the goal marked as g in the
top right corner
and
once the dyna q agent has learned this
policy correctly which is shown in the
plot by the cumulative reward becoming
linear in the number of steps well at
that point we change the environment to
the one on the right
which is very similar very similar grid
but now the optimal policy is not
anymore to move
to the right to reach the goal but
rather the agent needs to take a detour
to
circumnavigate that wall that is now
blocking the path
when you do this change in environment
suddenly the cumulative reward collected
by dyna q flattens because that at the
beginning the agent will try to continue
move toward through the same path that
it had
learned at the beginning but of course
that path is now blocked because the
walls have shifted
this means that for a few steps the
agent will be unable to collect any
rewards
but if you look at the plot for dyna
queue after a while the agent
does start collecting more rewards
because the agent will update the model
to now correctly understand that that it
cannot move through that cell because
it's now a wall
and through planning it will then
re-route the the policy of the agent
through by updating the q values in
order to take the
a different route and which which now
results in the reward again growing
linearly with the number of steps
there are several specific agents on
this plot and again this plot is taken
from the sutton invarta book
but
that correspond to slightly different
instantiations of dyna and
the middle one is dyna q which is the
canonical one i described while dyna q
plus adds some small exploration box
which means that actually
is able to reroute slightly faster but
the core message remains that
if the model is inaccurate in this way
where
the the world actually is harder than
the model was initially assuming
the behavior of the agent is such that
it will actually lead to
real transitions that will correct for
the model error and therefore the in
some sense the learning dynamic is
overall quite benign
it's good to realize that this is not
always the case so let's now consider a
very similar setting with a slight
difference so now again the world
changes
but
the change in environment is actually
easier in some sense so at the beginning
you have
the situation on the left where the
agent needs to take this detour around
the wall in order to reach the goal
but after changing there is now
the detour is still available to the
agent but another path has opened up so
the agent could take pass to the right
of the wall which is a slightly shorter
path which would result in higher
rewards
what happens is that once
the q agent has learned to
correctly
take this detour long detour around the
wall in order to reach the goal
there is nothing that pushes the agent
to explore this other path the the way
in which the model is incorrect the fact
that there is actually a small
is a shorter path
is
is not reflected in the data that the
agent sees because the the error in the
model
doesn't result in data that can correct
for the model error itself so what
happens is that once the agent has
converged on the solution of taking the
long detour it actually might stay just
stick with this behavior and will take a
very very long time in order to to
realize that there was actually an error
and this is why in this plot the dyna q
algorithms exactly which is
exactly the one i described in the
pseudocode before will actually continue
learning at the same speed
the slope is the same because it's still
taking always the same long path in
order to reach the goal after also after
that the world itself has become easier
and here you can see actually the dyna q
plus that adds this exploration bonus is
actually able to figure out this
this additional path and i don't want to
go into much details about dyna q plus
because the details are not important
here but
the important thing to understand is
that thinking deeply for instance about
exploration is still important even
model-based rl because
the way the
certain types of errors in your in your
model might not necessarily be
discovered unless you have something
that pushes your agent to to execute
this behavior that results in useful
data
the dyna algorithms i described in the
previous section is a beautiful
instantiation of a system that
integrates learning and planning so
model-free and model-based updates but
it's not the only one and in this
section i want to discuss experience
replay and its connection to more
conventional model based algorithms such
as dynam
traditionally rl algorithms
did not explicitly store experience so
it was trivial to place them in one of
two groups so model-free methods that do
not attempt to explicitly model the
dynamics of the environment and directly
update values and policy online with the
latest data
a model-based methods that learn
transitions and reward model and then
plan value functions using such a model
but this kind of sharp distinction
is blurred not just by
algorithms like dyna that do both but by
other developments for instance in the
space of model 3 algorithms
and indeed many modern rl systems
now store transitions in an experience
replay buffer and then apply model-free
algorithms not just to the latest
transitions but also to pass transitions
in the buffer
and this is actually a fairly common
technique for model free agents but it
also can be seen as just instantiating
dyna but with an experience replay
playing the role of a non-parametric
model
and this is not just a
superficial similarity because both
systems actually share a fundamental
property like which is their ability to
sync in compute as i said many times
with no additional environment
interactions to improve values and
policies
and in this case the
experience replace systems would do so
by making many updates on past
experience for every new real steps in
the environment
in
in this plot here i
i can show that how this
this property of the scalability
property of planning algorithms um is
instantiated by both dyna and a replay q
learning agent in the case of a simple
grid world so this is a simple grid
world where as usual you start in the
state s and you need to reach the goal g
as fast as possible because there is
some some discount strictly smaller than
one
and what i
show on the right side is basically the
total number of steps required to reach
the goal on the on the top right
25 times if you every time you start
from the cell
s on the left
as a function of the amount of planning
so of the amount of updates that you do
for each real step in the environment
and you can see that regardless of
whether the entire transition is
replayed like an experience replace
system or whether a model is used to
infer the subsequent rewards and state
given a state action pair the profile
actually looks very similar the more
additional updates you do for every real
step in the environment the more the
performance improves and so the faster
you reach the goal thing which is
basically the lower the total number of
steps that are required to reach the
goal 25 times
and you might might be even tempted to
take this to the extreme so our
experience replace system and algorithms
based on learn parametric models
completely equivalent
and well in the tabular settings we can
actually derive exact equivalences
between certain model-based and
model-free algorithms
and even more in general somewhat
trivial if we had a perfect model that
outputs exactly the same
true reward and successor state as the
non-parametric replay system well the
two would be exactly equivalent by
construction
in general though of course any model
that we use will not be perfect so one
question that you may ask is will it
ever be better
could the inaccuracy that almost
certainly come from using a parametric
model provide benefits on top of a
non-parametric replay system
this seems unlikely and it's i think
it's fair to say that if we only use the
model to reconstruct their words and
successor states corresponding to an
observed state action pair it seems hard
for a parametric model to improve over
just replaying those transitions
but the reason that algorithms like dyna
and model base rl that use parametric
learn models are so important is
actually a parametric model allows
flexibility that goes way beyond that
so for instance we could use the model
to plan for action selection and this is
something we'll discuss in great detail
in the next section because
if you can query a parametric model for
actions that you could want to take in
the future then you can use this to
construct a plan to decide how to act
and this is something that you cannot do
if you're just have a non-parametric
replay system that can only tell you
which action you took in the past in a
given state
additionally with a
parametric model you could do things
like counterfactual planning so queria
models for actions that you could have
taken in the past but did not
and related to contrafractual planning
you could do what is called backward
planning so if instead of modeling the
actual dynamics of the problem you model
the inverse dynamics so given a state
and an action you you the model tries to
predict what was the previous reward and
previous state well then you can use
this to assign credit to states that
could have led to a certain outcome in
addition to assigning credit as in
standard rl to the states that actually
preceded that outcome
and finally if you have a parametric
model you could train this model to add
different time skills like an algorithm
like dyna doesn't need not to be
restricted to train a model exactly on
one step transitions
you and on the true native time scale of
the environment you could train a model
to do jumpy predictions and therefore
call support what is called jumpy
planning
and in conclusion it's actually worth
noting also that there are computational
differences between the parametric model
and experience replay so
and this might also uh actually play an
important role in choosing between the
two so for instance querying a replay
buffer is very cheap given a state
action pair it gives you immediately
what was the reward and what was the
successor state that you observed in the
past
well given a state action pair
generating a subsequent reward in state
using a learned model could be very
expensive if the learn model for
instance is parameterized by a big
neural network
and
if you look at memory of course things
change and for instance the memory
requirements of a replay buffer can be
quite harsh because the memory will
scale linearly with its capacity
well a parametric model could achieve
good accuracy with a fixed and
and comparably smaller memory footprint
and overall i think the the the key
takeaway that i would like you to get is
that
both are important and powerful ideas
that implement this core principle of
planning this capability of syncing in
compute in order to improve
our learning and our algorithms and
regardless of the labels that we want to
attach to them it's really
more important to just think deeply
about the problem that you want to solve
and whether a parametric or a parametric
model can be the best fit for for that
specific problem
so far we discussed how planning can be
used to improve our estimates of a
global value function or a global policy
that is applicable in all the states of
our mdp
but now i want to tell you about a
different form of planning where we sync
and compute as usual without requiring
additional interactions with the
environment but for the purpose of just
selecting a single action in a single
state
this is something is also called
planning in the nail and it may seem a
special case of the previous problem and
of course in a sense it is because
if we could get perfect values and
perfect policies everywhere then we
could just use these perfect values in
any one state
but the motivation for investigating
planning for action selection is that
sometimes it's actually easier to make a
very accurate local value function than
it is to actually fit the global by
function and the reason is that
in in planning if a value function for
the current state we only need to take
into account the distribution of states
that are are reachable from the current
state and that that might be a very
small portion of the overall mdp
and additionally planning for action
selection has a few other appealing
properties like the fact that
suppose you have some inaccuracy in your
model in in some states well that will
only affect the local throwaway values
that you're using to select an action
right now
but it won't pollute like a shared
global value function that is going to
be reused everywhere so it might result
in sure selecting a sub-optimal action
in certain poorly understood states but
maybe that just leads to reasonable
exploration and for instance
behaviors that can help you correct your
the model itself
the simplest form of planning for the
purpose of action selection is what is
called forward search so
this approach
allows you to select the best action in
any given state by basically building
the entire search tree that has the
current state as root and then follows
all possible
trajectories from from the current state
onwards until episode terminations
basically this approach is amounts to
representing as a tree the entire
sub-mdp of reachable states from the
current one and in some cases this sub
mdp might actually be fairly tiny and
then you can maybe solve that in full
every time you need to select an action
in general of course this might not be
the case so in in general the number of
the states in the tree will actually
grow exponentially for instance with the
depth and so even with a fairly small
action space it might be computationally
intractable if the horizon that you need
to look
look to
goes beyond a few handful of steps
but
this is still a reasonable thing to
consider at least from a conceptual
perspective because then
sure we have a problem with branching
but we have dealt with branching in the
past so similarly to how we did for
learning global value functions we can
again use sampling also for solving
these local mdps just for the purpose of
action selection and this actually
results in what is called simulation
based search
here you
we we construct a partial tree so
basically we start as usual from the
current state as the root of some tree
but then we construct
a subset of the full tree by simulating
multiple episodes of experience that all
start from the current state and then
use the model to roll forward possible
sequences of actions
if you construct such a partial tree
then then you can just for instance
apply model 3rl to the simulated
episodes to estimate the values in the
root
so for instance you could instantiate
simulation-based search
by
using multi-current prediction to
estimate the state value of a root node
by doing just by using just two
components you have some learned model
and some simulation policy
and then the state value in the root
will just be estimated by
sampling using the model and the policy
k episode referred and then just
averaging this to estimate the state
value of the root
of course if we're interested in
planning for action selections and we
are
just the state the value in the root
might not be that useful so often we
will want to actually construct action
values but the same principles apply
very very naively just also to plan the
local action value functions in this
case we'll need
k times the number of actions episodes
to ensure we sample each action k times
in the root but apart from that then we
can use the same mechanism to generate
complete episodes from the model and the
simulation policy and then just again
use averaging to estimate
the the value of each action in the root
as the average of the returns that did
execute that that action immediately in
the root and then followed the
simulation policy afterwards
if we construct such a local action
value function then it's trivial to turn
this into a mechanism for action
selection because we we could for
instance in each state always pick the
action with the highest value according
to our local search
in the simulation based search
algorithms that that i just described
each simulation is independent of the
previous ones
and
this means that we might not actually be
making the best use of the available
compute so it has some computational
advantages because it's fully
parallelizable
but at the same time we are not using
what we have learned by rolling the
model forward until the end of the
episode to guide our behavior in the
next simulation
so in this in in this second part i want
to discuss
a different approach where we build the
tree incrementally so that we can
leverage knowledge from previous
simulation in order to focus our
computational resources where they
matter most
so the algorithm is called the monte
carlo research and was for instance at
the heart of the famous alpha zero
system and alphago and more recently the
mu0 system that
that showed that they could
literally learn at the level of world
champions games like go chess shogi and
even video games
and the algorithm is fairly simple
because it's just based on repeating the
following four steps until you have
exhausted the computational
time or computational resources that you
have allocated to the action selection
and on each step for each simulated
episode what you do is just you
start from the root
and you use your current estimates of
the q values based on the previous
simulations to
walk all the way from the root to a leaf
node in the tree
then what you do is you add the node to
the tree by expanding the the action
with the highest value in the leaf node
you then use
a rollout until episode termination
using a fixed stimulation policy to get
a complete evaluation of of that that
that path in the tree and then you walk
backwards all the way to the root
updating all the q values of all the
ancestor ancestor nodes in the tree
and once you have exhausted the
available time and resources you just as
in the previous algorithm just select
the action in the root that has the
highest value
the the important feature of this
approach is that effectively we have two
policies we are not always expanding
nodes and building the tree using a
fixed stimulation policy instead we have
a tree policy that we use to navigate
from the root to a leaf
that is based on all the previous
simulations so it's guided by all that
we have learned in the previous
simulations in the in this state
and then we have a rollout policy that
is this indeed fixed that we use to get
the monte carlo estimate of the return
from the leaf onwards
and often the the the advantage is that
we the rollout policy might be very
cheap so for instance we could just have
a random policy even that can be
surprisingly effective but because we
are iterating on the tree policy that we
use to navigate all the way to the leaf
the the system actually allocates
resources and compute quite effectively
and can result in very good
value estimates
of course at this stage it might still
feel a bit fuzzy so as usual let's try
to walk through a concrete example so we
can understand how this algorithm works
in practice
and
let's consider a situation where we have
some state that we are interested to
select an action in
and we have always two actions in every
state
so at the beginning the tree is empty so
what we do is we just
the the initial state is is a leaf
itself and we just use a default policy
to
to roll out until an episode termination
so this will for instance give us
if we roll out the policy in the model
until we the model tells us that the
episode has terminated maybe we get a
reward a return of one
then we update our value of the root
node to be one because it's the average
of the existing
simulations
then we expand
one node
so for instance we have
no additional knowledge let's say we
simply randomly choose to pick the the
right action
then what we do is again we have reached
the leaf we use the default rollout
policy to get in the entire episode
evaluation
this time we observe that we get an
absolute return of zero
but now we go back and we update not
just the node we had just expanded but
all the ancestors ancestors which now
included the root node so the evaluation
of the node we just expanded will be
zero but the evaluation of the value of
the root will have been updated to one
half
since the value in the root is higher
than the value of
the actions that we have selected then
let's try to to expand the different
action
and again after
reaching this leaf node we use the
rollout policy to get an evaluation this
time we serve a return of one so we
update the value of this node we just
expanded but also the root so the root
is now has the value of two thirds and
each of the actions in the root have an
estimate of one and zero respectively
since the
the the value in the on the left side is
higher let's now again we navigate until
the leaf we expand one node we do an
evaluation this time we observe a zero
we back up
all the updates so the the newly upped
added node has a value of zero his
parent has now a value of one half and
the root node now have also a value of
one half because two out of four the
episodes that started in the route uh
had the reward of one and the other two
had no reward at all
again we navigate until the leaf we pick
the action with the with the highest
value
and we expand that node we roll out
until the end we get an evaluation of
one
now again we have
we have to update all the values in the
parent nodes to include this the latest
information that we have generated with
this rollout again you start in the node
you follow the q values to reach the the
leaf by always selecting the highest
value and then expand again
and if you iterate this process you
basically get a very highly selective
best first search
where states are evaluated dynamically
and we are using sampling to break the
cursive dimensionality
and while still being computational
efficient because the algorithm is is
anytime so you can basically iterate
until you have computational resources
until you have time to think
and then at any point you get a best
estimate of what what the
the agent can assume the values in the
route to be given the policy and the
model that it had available
an important thing to realize though is
that
monte carlo research that actually
basically all the simulation based and
even forward search
are essentially table lookup approaches
but based not on instantiating the table
of all possible states but instantiating
a partial table that only includes the
most
likely state or that are directly
reachable from the current state
so
we discussed quite extensively that for
model 3rl table lookup is maybe a bit
naive so you cannot possibly store
values for all states you don't and
because you don't get any generalization
you you will likely not have trained the
value or a policy for any new state that
you encounter when interacting with the
environment but for simulation based
search the table lookup is actually less
naive because you only need to store
store values for the easily reachable
states that are likely under the policy
and under your q value estimate
so even if you don't have extensive
generalization this can actually be a
system that works quite well in practice
at the same time there are limits so
it is still a partial instantiation of a
table
and that that could grow to be very
large so for very big search spaces it
will still be useful to combine these
ideas from mcts with for instance value
function approximation this is for
instance what actually the alphago
system did it actually used value
functions and policies to guide the
search and in its later iterations even
to replace the rollout the rollouts to
get a multi-car evaluation
by rolling a leaf all the way to the end
replacing that with just a learn value
function to to basically make the
process more efficient